marie agnes strack zimmermann von der
fdp ist die vorsitzende des
verteidigungsausschusses
aktuell in finnland unterwegs schönen
guten morgen
guten morgen reicht das was die
bundesregierung da jetzt beschlossen hat
also es ist erstmal gut und richtig dass
sie es beschlossen hat und ob das reicht
das wird das zeigen wie der creeks
verlauf ist wir befürchten dass es nicht
reicht dass wir kontinuierlich weiter
machen müssen denn das ziel von wladimir
putin ist ja die ganze ukraine zu
unterwerfen bzw von der landkarte zu
löschen insofern müssen wir dranbleiben
nicht reicht unter anderem auch deshalb
weil viele experten und expertinnen ja
auch davon ausgehen dass der krieg
möglicherweise noch viele monate oder
sogar jahre dauern könnte ist denn die
rechnungen die ich da gerade aufgemacht
habe eigentlich richtig rechnet scholz
aktuell zu den 500 millionen nicht auch
dinge ein die er schon vergangene woche
angekündigt hatte wie raketenwerfer
präzisionsmunition und ähnliches
wissen sie ich glaube dass es jetzt gar
nicht jungen der rechnung geht sondern
letztlich darum was am ende dabei
rauskommt tatsache ist dass das ganze
etwas schleppend begonnen hat jetzt
fahrt aufnimmt und die uns vorbereiten
müssen auf den herbst nämlich dahin
gehen was ist wenn der krieg länger geht
in dieser krieg wird nur beendet wenn
putin seine soldaten zurückzieht davon
können wir nicht ausgehen insofern
schauen wir natürlich im ausschuss genau
hin was freigegeben worden ist vom
wirtschaftsministerium aber am
wichtigsten was am ende auch in der
ukraine ankommt was in der ukraine
ankommt wenn man natürlich dass mit
einrechnet was man schon angekündigt hat
dann sind die 500 millionen halt eben
nicht ganz konkret aber gut warum wartet
die ukraine eigentlich weiter auf
schnell verfügbare kampf und
schützenpanzer aus beständen der
industrie können sie uns das erklären
ja also wir hatten ja den bundeskanzler
gebeten dass wir auch direkt an die
ukraine schützenpanzer liefern
möglicherweise auch kampfpanzer weil das
einfach dringend gebraucht wird sie
müssen sich vorstellen die ukraine
wendet sich an den besten hat ganz
konkrete bitten am besten bespricht sich
auch durchaus ab was kann der liefern
und da könnten wir deutlich offensiver
sein an der stelle ist allerdings das
kanzleramt ausgesprochen zurückhaltend
bedauerlicherweise
was fordern sie denn da müsste dann
deutschland eventuell auch schwere
waffen aus den beständen der bundeswehr
liefern wäre das eine ihrer forderung
ja das wäre eine möglichkeit zumal die
industrie uns gesagt hat sie könnte um
beim bei den panzern aber als vergleich
zu bleiben wenn wir 50 direkt liefern
würden könnte die industrie innerhalb
eines jahres diesen bestand der
bundeswehr wieder auffüllen wichtig ist
ja das argument besser gesagt der
bundeswehr ist ja häufig besser gesagt
als generalinspekteur ist es würde dann
schälen tatsache ist aber dass diese
auseinandersetzung dieser krieg in der
ukraine
ja ganz europa unmittelbar angeht und
insofern macht es sinn sozusagen in die
vorhand zu gehen ist zu liefern und dann
wieder innerhalb kürzester zeit zurück
zu bekommen jetzt haben sie gerade
dieses mantra wiederholt was viele sagen
in der ukraine wird die freiheit europas
verteidigt ist dieses hier ein bisschen
da ein bisschen nicht auch in anbetracht
der wirtschaftsleistung und der
vermeintlichen führungsrolle
deutschlands nicht ich will nicht sagen
peinlich aber ein bisschen wenig
naja das ist die diskussion die wir seit
wochen führen welche rolle spielt
deutschland eigentlich mein wenn man sie
sprechen von mantra jetzt momentan
kämpft die ukraine ums überleben und
zwar ums nackte überleben sie haben das
bild gerade gezeigt aber der angriff auf
die ukraine ist ja nichts neues seitens
putin erst einmal läuft ja schon seit 20
14 dann hat er die krim annektiert hat
georgien angegriffen tschetschenien
angegriffen bei in syrien genauso brutal
unterwegs hauptsache alles kaputtmachen
und zerstören und deswegen müssen wir
uns darauf einstellen dass es ihnen
darum geht die freiheit in der wir leben
die demokratie und menschenrechte gelten
zerstören zu wollen deswegen müssen wir
im westen nicht nur deutschland auch
unsere europäischen partner uns schon
ernsthaft damit uns gedanken machen was
heißt das eigentlich für die zukunft
deswegen sind wir ja auch so an der
seite der ukraine und das sollten wir
auch in den nächsten monaten bleiben und
deshalb haben sie jetzt zum beispiel
auch eine opferbereitschaft aus der
bevölkerung gefordert ist das aus ihrer
position heraus nicht ein bisschen
wohlfeil
wissen sie es geht ja gar nicht darum
dass ich etwas fordere ich hab
sensibilisiert daraufhin da jetzt auf
gegenwind kommt mein egal was ich mache
das kennen sie irgendeiner bindet mir
immer entgegen das ist gar nicht das
thema sondern die frage ist doch es
verändern sich doch gerade dinge die
lage verändert sich das was wir die
gewissheiten die wir jahrzehntelang
hatten und die sind mit diesem krieg
vorbei und deswegen glaube ich jeder für
sich natürlich nach dessen was er
überhaupt schultern kann ist glaube ich
wohl aufgerufen auch mal veränderungen
anzunehmen und mal zu reflektieren was
man selber verändern kann darum geht es
hier und das betrifft uns alle nicht
genauso wie sie oder andere natürlich je
breiter die schultern je größer auch der
einsatz diesbezüglich aber ich glaube
wir sollten uns auch ehrlich machen so
zu tun als ob dieser krieg russlands
dieser angriff auf die ukraine uns allen
egal sein kann ist ja weit weg und alles
geht weiter wie bisher das ist nicht so
und ich kenne die auseinandersetzung
sollten wir führen und das mache ich
auch gerne frau strack zimmermann ich
glaube das haben in deutschland ziemlich
viele auch verstanden und leben
dementsprechend manchmal rost der not
heraus danach vielen dank für das
gespräch heute das war die
verteidigungsexpertin der fdp gerade
auch in finnland unterwegs um sich dort
mit kollegen und kolleginnen aus dem
finnischen verteidigungsausschuss und
auch mit dem minister vor ort
auszutauschen danke ihnen sehr
ich danke ihnen